I only stopped binging when I started eating intuitively
and I stopped dieting
I know this is a troll comment because she stays in my comments
however I think this is a really good opportunity to talk about how
binge eating is often the result of restriction right
at least for me
because I grew up a
a fat kid like
I've always been fat
I have been on diet since
you know I was a child
I honestly don't remember a time before I was dieting and constantly
like worrying about my weight
and because I grew up fat
I was constantly worried about becoming bigger
I grew up yo yo
dieting and like
in the cycle of restriction and binging and restriction and binging
and being forced on these diets as a child
messed up my relationship with food to a degree that I'm like
I'm still recovering from
I have a big sweet tooth and like sweets were
such a no no growing up
um and whenever I would get my hands on like
chocolate or whatever
instead of just like
having a piece because I was craving it and then like
leaving it for later
I would eat the entire thing because I knew I wasn't supposed to have it
I didn't know if it would be taken away from me
like I
I knew it was like
you know fleeting right
and so I would binge on that thing just
like having a piece and then moving on
I felt so much shame around the food that I was eating that like
I just like wanted to have it and then I didn't wanna think about it
and like that was one of the things that caused me to binge
and then when I started being in charge of the food that I ate
being control of the groceries that I bought
when I ate what I ate whatever
I switched from like
binging to eating what my body wanted
and not restricting the foods that I wanted to eat
which in turn caused me to have a better relationship with food
because I didn't eat from this position of like restriction
because of my cycle of yo-yo dieting in my childhood
I was continuously losing and gaining weight all the time
and that is what caused the weight gain that I had throughout my life
when I stopped dieting and I stopped restricting myself and started eating just
what I wanted
that is when my weight maintained
since I started eating intuitively
this is the first time in my entire life that my weight is the same
and you don't have to believe me
like I I'm
what do I gain from lying though
like this is
this is my reality
this is what happened in my life
I'm not denying like
I did binge eat
that was something that I definitely
definitely did
and I don't really anymore
intuitive eating is what has helped me with that
that being said
I think it's really interesting the way that people talk about
eating disorders that result in like
weight gain versus eating disorders that
like make people look emaciated
y'all's lack of empathy for fat people is very telling of your character